maybe the track meets have hormone
categories and maybe giving yourself the
wrong hormones is dous to your health
would you not admit that why are you on
the side of people who don't know the
difference between boys and girls
because if you if we can't lay out that
basic stuff the things that we all know
to be true then when it gets to really
complex stuff like geopolitics let's say
then how's anyone going to know what is
true I thought it was a little bizarre
when Neil de grass heison was like oh
well this doesn't have anything to do
with science I'm pretty sure gender has
something to do uh with science but
degrass Tyson is really hung up on this
nonsense around uh boys and girls and
sports he simply for some reason wants a
bunch of biological males to dunk over
chicks or Smash Girls in the face when
they're playing LaCrosse or wrestle them
to the ground and put their knee on
their throat or whatever else so Bill's
going off on him we're going to show you
one more clip from this bill's going off
on him on that and then he has a he has
he's very smart he's a lefty and a
liberal so he he has many ideas on how
to deal with this gender stuff when it
comes to sports match more interesting
for the viewer so if we can split
wrestling into 10 categories and that
becomes the wrestling match but all men
against each other correct so so now
sort of key Point okay okay so all I'm
saying is what is it that makes the man
the man is it the hormones okay is it if
it's the hormones and
you decide to give yourself a different
cocktail of hormones I'm making this up
by the way I'm not saying it should
happen this way it's a way to start
thinking about it maybe the track Meats
have hormone categories and maybe giving
yourself the wrong hormones is dilus to
your health would you not admit that do
you think we can just safely do things
like this so you feel this way because
you're concerned about you're so deeply
concerned about the health of the people
which trying to find their place on the
gender Spectrum you care about their
health so much that you don't want them
to go through that it's not something
that keeps me up at night but when the
subject comes up I care about them like
I care about all people so if there is
something you do by the way you think
about all people of course yeah is that
I give you that okay you're being think
about all people no I'm being I do yes
yeah old school liberal yeah okay so uh
I want all people to have you know make
this very challenging world that live in
better so that's why there's honest
debate about this issue and we why don't
we cut it off debate honest why don't we
cut it off now because like we're not
going to solve this we set our
pieces nice job Bill and Bill actually
at that moment that's proving that the
good liberal can still exist right
because when he's saying he cares about
both people like the grass Tyson is
trying to dismiss him like you don't
really care about these gender confused
people you're just trying to like what
what he's in essence saying is you're
just plating to those mean people on the
right who don't want it and it's like no
bill actually is saying I do care about
someone who might be young and confused
about their gender or whatever else but
at the same time that doesn't mean I
have to throw out logic and reason so
that we fill them full of hormones and
have them Crush people of the opposite
sex when it comes to
sports